our military through the North American
Aerospace Defense command so-called
North NORAD closely scrutinized
the our airspace including enhancing our
radar to pick up more slow moving
objects above our country
around the world in doing so they
attract three unidentified objects one
Alaska Canada and over Lake Huron in the
Midwest
they acted in accordance with
established parameters for determining
how to deal with unidentified aerial
objects in U.S airspace
at third recommendation I gave the order
to take down these three objects due to
hazards to civilian commercial air
traffic and because we could not rule
out the surveillance risk of sensitive
facilities
we acted in consultation with the
Canadian government I spoke firstly with
prime minister Trudeau and Kant from
Canada on Saturday
and just as critically we acted out of
an abundance of caution and an
opportunity that allowed us to take down
these these objects safely
our military and the Canadian military
are seeking to recover the debris so we
can learn more about these three objects
our intelligence Community is still
assessing all three incidences they're
reporting to me daily and will continue
their urgent efforts to do so and I will
communicate that to the Congress
we don't yet know exactly what these
three objects were
but nothing nothing right now suggests
they were related to China's spy balloon
program or that there were surveillance
vehicles from other any other country
intelligence community's current
assessment is that these three objects
were most likely balloons tied to
private companies Recreation or research
institutions studied weather or
conducting other scientific research
when I came into office I instructed our
intelligence Community to take a broad
look at the phenomenon of unidentified
aerial objects
we know that a range of entities
including countries companies and
research organizations operate objects
at altitudes for purposes that are not
nefarious including legitimate
scientific research I want to be clear
we don't have any evidence that there
has been a sudden increase in the number
of objects in the sky we're now just
seeing more of them partially because
the steps we've taken to increase our
Radars to narrow our radars and we have
to keep adapting our approach to uh
delaying to dealing with these
challenges that's why I've directed my
team to come back to me with sharper
rules for how we will deal with these
unidentified objects moving forward
distinguishing distinguish between those
that are likely to pose Safety and
Security risk that necessitate action
and those that do not
but make no mistake
if any object presents a threat to the
safety security of the American people I
will take it down
I'll be sharing with Congress these
classified policy parameters when
they're completed and there'll remain
classified so we don't give our road map
to our enemies to try to evade our
defenses
going forward these parameters will
guide what actions will take while
responding to unmanned and unidentified
aerial objects we're going to keep
adapting them as the challenges evolve
if it evolves in addition we've directed
my National Security advisor to lead a
government-wide effort to make sure we
are positioned to deal safely and
effectively with the objects in our
airspace first we will establish a
better inventory of unmanned Airborne
objects in space above the United States
airspace and make sure that inventory is
accessible and up to date
second we'll Implement further measures
to improve our capacity to detect
unmanned objective objects in our
airspace
third we'll update the rules and
regulations for launching and
maintaining unmanned objects in the
skies above the United States of America
and fourth my secretary of state will
lead an effort to help establish a
global a global common Global Norms in
this largely unregulated space
these steps will lead to safer and more
secure skies for our air Travelers our
military our scientists and for people
on the ground as well
that's my job as your president
commander-in-chief
as the events of the previous days have
shown will always act to protect the
interest of the American people on the
security of the American people
since I came to office we've developed
the ability to identify track and study
high altitude surveillance balloons
connected with the Chinese military
when one of these high altitude
surveillance balloons entered our
airspace over the continental United
States earlier in the month I gave the
order to shoot it down as soon as it
would be safe to do so the military
advised again shooting it down over land
because of the sheer size of it it was
the size of multiple school buses and
opposed a risk to people on the ground
if it was shot down where people lived
instead we tracked it closely
we analyze his capabilities and we
learned more about how it operates and
because we knew its path we were able to
protect sensitive sites against
collection
we waited until it was safely over water
which would not only protect civilians
but also enable us to recover
substantial components for further
analysts for for further Analytics and
then we shot it down sending a clear
message clear message the violation of
our sovereignty is unacceptable
we'll act to protect our country and we
did
now this past Friday we put restrictions
on six firms that directly support the
People's Republic Liberation Army
people's people's Liberation Army
Aerospace program that includes airships
and balloons denying them access to U.S
technology
we briefed our diplomatic partners and
our allies around the world and we know
about China's program and where their
balloons have flown
some of them have also raised their
concerns directly with China
our exports have lifted components of
the Chinese balloons payload off the
ocean floor
we're analyzing them as I speak and what
we learn will strengthen our
capabilities
now we'll also continue to engage with
China
as we have throughout the past two weeks
as I've said since the beginning of my
Administration we seek competition not
conflict with China we're not looking
for a new Cold War but I make no
apologize I make no apologies and we
will compete and will be will
responsibly manage that competition so
that it doesn't Veer into conflict
this episode underscores the importance
of maintaining open lines of
communication between our diplomats and
our military professionals our diplomats
will be engaging further and I will
remain in communication with President
XI
I'm grateful for the work of the last
several weeks of our intelligence
diplomatic and Military professionals
who approve once again to be the most
capable in the world
and I want to thank you all now look the
other thing I want to point out is that
we are going to keep our allies and the
Congress contemporaneously informed at
all we know and all we learn and uh I
expect to be speaking with President XI
and I hope we have come we are going to
get to the bottom list but I make no
apologies for taking down that balloon
thank you very much
[Music]